hey what's up so today i want to walk
you through a vfx
technique that i use in a hundred
percent of my photo reel renders
it's actually the technique i'm using to
light this cg ball right here
and that's with a custom the keyword is
custom
hdri and in this video i'm going to show
you how easy it is
to make your own high dynamic range
images or
hdris are special for a couple reasons
first when exposed up or down they
actually retain proper
exposure values unlike other file types
this works because they're made from a
combination
of multiple images taken at various
exposures and secondly when wrapped
around
a cg environment you can actually use
the image
to light your scene okay so to begin
creating our custom hdri
we need to take a series of bracketed
images
at different exposures of our 360 degree
environment and there's a few ways to do
this but i'll start with
the easiest way this is a 360 camera
specifically the 1r from insta360
it has two lenses each capturing one
half of the environment
and i love this thing because it's small
very portable and super easy to use
so the next thing you need to do is
figure out where your cg element is
going to sit
in our case we had a chrome ball sitting
right here so i'd want to take my hdri
from right here it's going to match your
reflections
your lighting will be a lot more
accurate okay so the closer you can get
your
hdri image from to the actual place
where your cg object is going to be
sitting
then you're going to be set up for the
best bet okay you want to use
a monopod when you're doing this this
360 camera is so wide
it's going to capture any legs of a
tripod no problem it even captures
these legs right here so you just want
to make sure that when you're shooting
this thing
you're using a monopod so you don't have
to paint out all your tripod legs in
photoshop
i got this for like i don't know 50 60
bucks on amazon
super easy super cheap so now all we
have to do is take our bracketed images
just make sure
your darkest image retains your
brightest highlight detail
and your brightest image retains your
shadow detail
now if you don't have a 360 camera you
can do this with a dslr and a tripod
this is actually the way that everyone
did it before 360 cameras came out
it's just gonna take a lot longer
because you're gonna have to take
an image at every single angle first a
full 360 with a level camera
second with the camera angle down at 45
degrees and lastly
up at 45 degrees now the upside to doing
it this way
is you'll have a super high res hdri and
you'll actually be able to use it as an
actual background because it's going to
be so high res but
in our case i think it's a little
overkill just because we're not using it
as a background we're using it to
inform our lighting for our scene as
well as the reflections so we just have
to keep in mind
what we're using it for so i think a
little overkill and takes a little too
long
so now let's talk about stitching all
right so since i shot on a 360 camera
i don't need to stitch anything together
it basically comes out as a full 360
panorama
right at the gates so that saves us a
ton of time
all we need to do is just convert them
from their native format
to jpegs so since i shot on an insta360
camera i am in
insta360 studio this is their
proprietary program
very simple very easy to use i'm just
going to drag these bad boys in
we got all of our shots on the left the
only thing you want to make sure of
is your stitching mode you want to make
sure that that is
normal across the board sometimes it
switches it
to like a dive case by default or
whatever
if you don't do this we're going to get
some unwanted ghosting effects
and no one likes ghosts no one wants to
be haunted so
definitely make sure that these
stitching options are uniform across
the board then all we'll do select
everything
batch export target resolution def
original of course yeah you want to go
for the highest quality and just put it
somewhere where
you won't forget now if you shot on a
dslr you're gonna have a couple
hundred images and you're gonna have to
take those and stitch them together
in a program like photoshop which is
actually pretty easy so let's just go
file automate photo merge
and for our purposes we want to choose a
cylindrical layout
so since we had three exposures we'll
have to do three photo merges so let's
just do one of these at a time
open all those and let's check vignette
removal geometric distortion correction
and content aware fill
transparent areas you can do this uh
after the fact as well
and we'll just hit ok wait a really long
time and you'll have your photo merge
just make sure you give it a crop i
usually do two by one
ratio and find the halfway point
somewhere around there
and you get a nice seamless stitch do
this for the rest of your exposures
so let's finally merge all of these
photos together to make our hdri
so i'm gonna drag the panoramas from the
360 camera into photoshop here
and you can see how the camera doesn't
move because we got our stitch settings
correct
so now we have all these images across
the top we've loaded in everything into
photoshop
all we need to do is go to file automate
merge to hdr pro so we're prompted with
this dialog box we'll just add
open files right that's everything that
we just dragged into
photoshop and we don't need to attempt
to automatically align source images
because we already checked that again
with
our stitch settings so let's just hit ok
boom so now we're looking at one
image and it's made up from all of these
images
that we took all right and you can see
here the exposure values we got
plus five almost then down to minus
ten so there's two settings we want to
check here
to make sure that this gets exported
properly first we wanna make sure we
complete our toning in adobe camera raw
if you don't check this the image might
come in dark in our 3d program
and the most important thing your mode
has to be set to 32
bits or else this will not work this
will not be an hdr image we can't even
save it as an hdr image
it'd be like frodo marching all the way
to mordor
in all three movies and at the end he's
just like you know what
you know i'm just gonna chill i actually
forgot the ring i'm gonna have to go
back for it
so let's just make sure guys this is at
32 and don't worry about removing any
ghost because we properly exercise this
footage
in the insta 360 studio application
all right so let's just hit tone and acr
and you can see here if we adjust the
exposure
it's actually retaining the highlights
unlike a jpeg where the lights will just
kind of gray out
we're still getting these really bright
uh white values here in the lights and
that's exactly what we want that's the
whole point of creating an hdri image
so that it can light our scene as
accurately as possible
but we don't need to adjust anything
here all right we're just going to hit
ok
and make sure you just undo the adobe
camera raw bit
again it's just the step we need to take
so that our hdr image doesn't come into
our 3d program looking all dark
so from this point you can totally just
clone stamp out your monopod
and slap a slap an exposure adjustment
on it you know
how you set the exposure here is how
it's going to look when we drop it into
our 3d program
and finally we'll go file save as
and make sure we save it as a radiance
file a dot
hdr all right high dynamic range boom
throw your new creation in a 3d scene
and render something sweet
so get out there guys and make some
custom light maps it's super fun
but if you guys would rather just buy a
pack or something and want to support
more videos like this
i actually put together a series of 14
post-apocalyptic battlefield inspired
hdris
i got them up on gumroad for y'all and
it's about the price of like a large
los angeles coffee but be sure to
subscribe because you do not want to
miss
my custom surface imperfection tutorial
we're going to be making our own
from scratch and in the meantime i'll
see you guys on saturday morning for my
cinema 4d live stream
we make cool stuff like this in this and
sometimes like this
and then i issue a weekly challenge to
you guys where we talk about it and work
on it
in the discord server the link's down
below as well but good luck on your cg
voyage i'll see you guys next time
peace
[Music]
bye